Republicans have hit a dead end trying
to repeal the Affordable Care Act
Trump said yesterday that he is ready to
let Obamacare fail after the Senate's
latest health care move ran into serious
trouble Republican moderates said
repealing Obamacare without a plan to
replace it would create confusion and
anxiety for many Americans and to
cortices on Capitol Hill Nancy good
morning good morning Senate Leader Mitch
McConnell is going to hold a vote early
next week on his last-ditch offer
repealing Obamacare without a
replacement even though he knows it is
going to fail he's trying to show House
Republicans and the White House that he
has exhausted all options and we finally
get a chance to repeal every place they
don't take advantage of it
president Trump blamed Democrats and a
few Republicans for his party's
inability to find consensus I think
we're probably in that position where
we'll just let Obamacare fail we're not
going to own it Senate Republicans
scaled back their ambitions Tuesday
hatching a plan to simply repeal
Obamacare without replacing it repealing
we all for replacing we're all over the
board I'm ready to vote to repeal I'm in
favor of the motion to proceed to
repealing Obamacare moderate Republicans
quickly pumped the brakes I believe it
would cause the insurance markets to go
into turmoil a bipartisan group of
Governors pleaded with the Senate to
reject efforts to repeal without a
replacement saying this could leave
millions of Americans without coverage
Senate Democrats said the only option
left was to negotiate with them they
thought they could do it on their own
now it's clear they can't and the door
is open again but Republicans have been
promising repeal for seven years and
have voted more than 60 times to try to
make it happen they'll take one last
vote in the coming days forcing those
moderates to put their no votes on the
record if that vote fails do you then
begin working with Democrats well I
think we'll have to see what happens we
will have demonstrated that Republicans
by themselves are not prepared at this
particular point
to do a replacement and that would come
as a huge blow to House Republicans who
went out on a limb to pass their own
replacement plan a few months ago only
to have president Trump turn around and
call it mean if Senate Republicans do
end up working with Democrats on a
package of fixes to Obamacare those
House Republicans Nora may not be in
much of a mood to accept it all right
Nancy thank you so much